So let me say it again cam i may be a
superhero but i'm also just a man who
fell in love with the wrong woman who's
the man who fell for the wrong woman
uh for the wrong woman but
out of crisis comes changed
i am very excited for everyone to meet the real
me there is something wrong with homelander
there's something broken
he's lost his mind
we've been on the straight and narrow all year
i'm killing supes no drinking even follow
hugh campbell's orders without strangling him
now you're just being cruel
or maybe you're not such an
people are superpowers
but real power isn't this it's the
ability to bend the world to your will
the gloves are off i thought we could fight about
the right way but we can't it's all
rigged we have to do it your way
we're all we've got it's up
to us i think i have something
maybe we can use it to blow homelanders brains out
what's this makes you a supe for
24 hours you're gonna need it
the whole point of what we do is that
no one should have that kind of power
for once i level the playing field
i show people the real me
i mean they love me
christ soldier boy
Welcome back everyone this will be my video for
the boys season three trailer there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs here we find out a little bit
more about jensen ackles soldier boy character and
how he gets released and what's going on with
butcher his compound v powers and what's going
on with homeland or just going completely off the
rails i'll be doing videos for all the episodes
just like i did for season 2 and season 1 so
be sure to subscribe to get everything we're
going to be getting episodes really soon we'll
just start at the beginning of the trailer talk
about all the moments and there are many moments
as we go along in easter eggs from the comics
they start with what seems like footage from early
in the episodes with homelander just slowly losing
his mind talking to these news broadcasters
you actually see that they're at the premiere
of the dawn of the seven which is the big justice
league in avengers endgame marvel parody that
they were shooting last year during season two
when he's talking about being a man who fell in
love with the wrong woman he's talking about
stormfront because they made a big deal about
their relationship i think later in the trailer
when we find out more about how they release
soldier boy from cold storage she's in that
special vought facility in cryostasis i think
that's actually what's happening to stormfront
right now she's in a facility kind of like that
i'll talk about jensen ackles character when we
get to that part of the trailer because it takes
a little while to actually reveal him but we learn
more about what his role in the actual series is
it is funny to see stan edgar in the background
watching homelanders he's losing his mind like
just making sure that you're saying everything
that i told you to say when he's talking to
starlight saying that real power isn't having
super powers itself like real power isn't being
homeland or flying around just being super strong
real power is bending the world to your will which
is all about their white house subplot in the
government voughts whole thing stan edgar's whole
thing is that he wants to control the white house
so that he can affect public policy because that's
where real power is if you can change the law then
that's real power that dovetails with what's going
on with victoria newman she's still really shady
obviously we see way more footage of her at bot's
headquarters because we know that she's a compound
v superhero that means that she would have had to
get compound v from vought at some point she's
based on the vic the veep character who was the
ceo of vod at one point in the comics obviously
it's different on the tv show in early theory
victoria newman is just part of his long game
to try and eventually control the white house
so even though the government has this new federal
branch this new department that's meant to police
superheroes that she's in control of that huey is
working for it sounds like stan edgar is secretly
controlling that and just using it to manipulate
the public and make them think that victoria
newman is really awesome so that eventually it
will advance her political career she can run for
office and that will be his plant in the white
house eventually because during the comic book
vic the veep is called vic the veep because
he is the vice president of the united states
inside the white house either way cannot wait to
see her popping some heads during season three
wouldn't be a season of the boys if they didn't
play with all of homelanders vices like he just
seems completely zoned out going straight to
the source getting his milk right from the cow
it also seems like he's sitting in a hospital
bed you can only imagine where that blood came
from but it just scenes of him being
a complete degenerate like you expect
just another tuesday pulling on another was that
a cow's letter well i remember that in the script
the whole thing with the butcher character
during the trailer is they're trying to show you
that he is potentially just as bad as homelander
especially when he gets super powers which is why
when they give him compound v superpowers with
that 24 hour green special serum his laserized
powers are obviously meant to be a joke about
laser baby like he has become the laser baby
this season but they look a lot like homelanders
powers because homelander has laser eyes he's not
the only person blowing up stuff like obviously
soldier boy goes completely crazy we'll learn more
about his true powers but they want to show you
butcher just going completely off the rails the
same way that homelander is going off the rails
is more than driving home that line in the trailer
where they say that no one is meant to have this
kind of power like anyone who gains this level of
power becomes terrible it's true of butcher is
true of homelander it's true of victoria newman
because she seems just as terrible as the rest of
them popping everyone's heads it really is a show
where everybody winds up being a different level
of terrible we find out a little bit what's going
on with ryan's character remember he's basically
the only deterrent that they have for homeland or
long term like it seems like soldier boy has some
crazy powers that he'll be using during the season
or losing control of during the season butcher
gets powers for at least 24 hours but really if
you're thinking about the long game potentially
they're setting up ryan as a sort of super boy
versus homelanders superman type of character by
the end of the series it's just that he's so young
right now he's not ready for something like that
but when all the characters start going off the
rails they show you him slowly going off the rails
so they're just trying to tease you that under the
right circumstances he could potentially become
just as bad as homelander eventually did the
funny joke about butcher following huey campbell's
orders remember he's working for victoria newman
he's trying to go on the straight and narrow but
like later in the trailer just within a short
period of time he says oh things don't work the
government doesn't work we have to do things your
way again rigo's the queen maeve who's the person
who gives him that special compound v formula
that'll give him powers for 24 hours without
making him explode one of the big things during
season two is they found that special facility
where they were experimenting on compound feed
trying to give it to adults without making them
die within the world of the boys compound v really
only works on children when they're babies if you
give it to adults it'll just kill them outright
so during season two they were just experimenting
with a way to give it to adults without doing that
and that's where the special green formula
comes from we get a bunch more scenes with
mother's milk's family we learn about his daughter
who's having her 10th birthday they're having a
seven-themed birthday party which is really ironic
given everything that they've done trying to fight
the seven the past couple seasons his daughter's
name janine she's dressed in the starlight costume
it also seems like his ex-wife has been remarried
to this person here he's dressed in a homelander
costume and she's had a son with him after she's
been remarried who's also dressed like homelander
which is even more ironic given how much happened
with homelanders the past couple seasons which is
all part of stan edgar's conversation that he
has with starlight about what real power is
controlling what people think and what they do
then the way they play the jensen ackles soldier
boy and payback reveal in the trailer they make it
sound like that's part of the compound v butcher
reveal too like the whole reason soldier boy winds
up coming back has something to do with butcher
trying to get it homelander in the seven so the
whole thing with the soldier boy reveal is they
show jensen ackles in flashbacks which seems
like maybe the vietnam war or the gulf war it
seems closer to the vietnam war one of the files
he has also seems like it goes all the way back to
world war ii era which is a big comic book easter
egg because we learned during season two that it
was actually stormfront who was technically the
world's first superhero like the first person to
actually survive a compound v treatment in the
comics soldier boy was the americans attempt
during world war ii to create their very first
superhero as well it was successful but he just
got captain america like powers in the trailer it
seems like this version of soldier boy that jensen
ackles is playing has way more secret compound
b powers that we're learning about because he
gives off all this pent up compound v energy
kind of like a bomb like he has bomb powers the
way they're playing this though is that payback
is just the team in the flashbacks that soldier
boy ran when he was active the big thing with the
payback team in the comics is that they're meant
to be this big marvel avengers parody and they're
sort of like a backup team to the seventh the
seven is still like the main superhero team in the
world of the boys payback is like the b team where
you put all the people who are almost ready to
go on the 7. this poster shows you everybody else
that was on the team it was black noir so it seems
like black noir has been around for a long time as
well lori holden is playing a version of crimson
countess who's their version of scarlet witch
sean patrick flannery is playing their version
of gunpowder with the guns he's a judge dread
parody these two twins are called the tnt twins
they're brand new characters that they created for
the show this character with the wings is called
swatto he's an ant-man parody or you could call
him a wasp parody this other character without
armor seems like he's meant to be a parody of
professor x in universe they have a team called
the g-men they're sort of like their version of
the x-men but they're meant to be just as terrible
as the characters that you see on the seven
if you zoom in enhance on his old file here you
can see him obviously wearing a much older looking
version of his costume that's meant to be another
easter egg for the comic book version it's like
captain america's old world war ii costume
before he got his brand new avengers costume
but you see in the file that vought found him
while he was in jail for gambling so it seems
like he was just this original common criminal
that vought experimented on with compound v
giving him powers and then turned him into an
early version of what homelander eventually became
and it seems like because he's been in cryostasis
and butcher breaks into this facility and just
accidentally finds him like what soldier boy
where'd you come from it seems like when he went
off the rails stan edgar wanted to control him
like put him on ice literally by putting him in
cryostasis and it seems like that's just what stan
edgar does to superheroes who go off the rails
so that's why i say that might be what he did
with stormfront at the end of last season because
the showrunner revealed that stormfront is
still alive even though she went completely
anakin skywalker got all of her limbs cut
off and turned into a piece of burnt toast
they also had that funny scene with jensen
ackles with that giant beard on that looks
like he's right after he comes out of cryostasis
is meant to be a big easter egg for the end of the
first captain america movie where he comes out
of the ice and looks around in present day and
just tries to acclimate to what things have turned
into while he's been on ice the douchiest version
of captain america you could possibly imagine but
if you have any questions about what's going on
in the trailer or any big easter eggs that you
spotted that i didn't talk about in my previous
trailer videos just write them below in the
comments we'll be getting episodes really soon
so obviously i will do episodes for everything
just like i did for season two will you wait for
everything click here for my full doctor strange
2 breakdown and easter eggs for the entire movie
and click here for my doctor strange 2 post
credit scene video and learn about who clea is
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!